[vent qui souffle]
Bonjour a tous peuple des Internet, voici la vidéo 19 de ce calendrier de l'Avent.
On approche du bout.
Et oui je ne sais pas pourquoi je parle comme ça.
Mais je parle comme ça.
Aujourd'hui je vous présente non pas 1,
non pas 2,
non pas 3,
non pas 4,
mais si en fait 4 !
Aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de vous parler de 4 jeux.
Ça aurait été compliqué de faire une vidéo pour chacun de ces jeux.
Par contre je trouvais qu'ils avaient un sens à en parler ensemble.
dans ces petites idées de cadeaux de Noël potentiels,
dans les jeux que je me suis procuré,
Ceux que j'aime beaucoup, ceux que je trouve juste sympa,
et ceux que j'aime moins bien je n'en parle pas,
car ça n'a pas tellement d'interêt !
On commence avec le jeu de Guillaume Pley: "Mempakap !"
Alors, on ne va pas se mentir, c'est Guillaume qui me l'a envoyé directement, je ne l'ai pas acheté.
C'est un jeu de 250 défis à jouer entre amis, de 2 à 6 joueurs.
Ce sont des défis simples, très très simples.
Exemple concret: défis stupide: "Envoie une grimace de toi par MMS".
Guillaume envoie toujours des MMS...!
Défi stupide: "Mets un doigt dans ton nez, puis dans ta bouche"
Défi physique: "le premier qui éteins la lumière gagne 1 point."
"tous les joueurs doivent ramener un objet commencant par un S".
Bon, on est clairement sur un jeu ludique, basique.
On ne va pas se mentir, c'est hyper basique,
Ça peut être très bien aussi pour des adolescents,
Maintenant, on n'est pas sur la révolution des jeux.
Qu'on soit bien d'accord.
C'est un jeu fun. Il fait le job.
Tu sais, c'est un peu comme les commentaires que tu as sur certains produits sur Amazon où il y a marqué:
"Conforme à la description."
Et bien, c'est ça.
Ce n'est pas un jeu révolutionnaire,
mais c'est conforme à la description.
C'est tout à fait ce qu'on attendait de ce jeu.
C'est le jeu de Guillaume Pley.
Lien dans la description.
On a donc en deuxième jeu, le jeu de Topito
qui a fait ça, et... [réfléchi]
Loic qui cadre cette vidéo et qui la monte, vient de me rappeller qu'on en a parlé dans la vidéo 5
Donc, je le mets ici... [rires]
Par contre, celle dont je n'ai pas parlé c'est le jeu de Cyrus North et Thomas Guilard qui s'appelle "T'imagine si".
Qui est sorti... chez qui d'ailleurs ? [réfléchi]
Chez Marabout.
Si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo de présentation,
je vous le mets dans la description.
C'est une des meilleures vidéos de présentation que j'ai vu pour un lancement de jeu de youtuber.
Ils ont eu un super concept.
Qui se passe en deux temps.
Il y a toujours un temps: "et si..."
et après il faut compléter avec une carte: "bah..."
Et ça me rappelle un peu le jeu: "Blanc Manger Coco", parce qu'il faut faire la meilleure proposition.
Exemple concret :
"-T'imagines si c'était interdit de s'asseoir..."
"-Bah, je me présenterai aux éléctions présidentielles."
Là, par exemple, ça ne se marie pas très bien.
Et vous devez trouver le meilleur mariage.
Et, après, et c'est là où ça devient intéressant,
contrairement aux autres jeux,
il faut argumenter.
Donc il faut avoir une argumentation solide sur pourquoi votre lien est meilleur qu'un autre lien.
Et, on a testé ça.
Et en fait, la partie elle dérive parce qu'on prend le truc hyper au sérieux,
et on se met à avoir un vrai argumentaire, à trouver des solutions pour que ça fonctionne, et tout...
C'est un jeu de créativité pur.
La règle paraît simple au départ et elle l'est,
Mais c'est aussi la difficulté de faire des bons jeux, c'est de trouver une règle simple.
"T'imagines si"
de Cyrus North et Thomas Guillard, lien dans la description.
Et quatrième jeu du jour,
"Apéro, la vache qui tâche".
[meuglement]
Cette imitation est incroyable !
"La vache qui tâche",
j'avais pris ce jeu parce que j'avais jeu quand j'étais petit qui étais aussi "La vache qui tâche",
avec un bouchon, on le brûlait, et on se faisait des tâches sur le front, et
il fallait être la vache qui tâche et qui a deux tâches,
et après la vache qui tâche sans tâches, etc...
Et le premier qui se trompait,
avait un gage.
Et comme on y jouait plutôt à une période jeune adulte,
les gages étaient souvent alcoolisés.
Donc quand j'ai vu le titre je me suis dis: "Super, je vais voir ce qu'ils en ont fait".
Alors, en fait, on peut y rejouer avec ces règles là,
mais c'est vraiment un jeu de questions de culture générale,
et de petits défis.
Ca reste un jeu marrant.
Je considère que c'est plus un jeu à offrir, qu'un jeu à s'offrir.
Voilà.
Je vous en ai parlé, parce que je me suis dit comme je vais vous faire un package de jeux dont je vais parler,
je vous le mets là-dedans pour vous le présenter.
Lien dans la description.
C'était une vidéo rapide.
On parlait un petit peu de jeux.
Ca m'a fait plaisir de vous voir.
J'espère que vous allez bien.
On se redonne rendez-vous demain à 6H00 du matin.
Pour la 20ème ouverture de ce calendrier de l'Avent.
Likez. Abonnez-vous.
Restez vous-même.
Couvrez-vous, il fait froid.
Ciao !
[meuglement]
[musique]